hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a professor of
philosophy and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called reason
I O where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for over
20 years and I find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic philosophical
texts sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that complicated and
that's where I come in to help students and
lifelong Learners I've been producing longer
lecture videos and posting them to YouTube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part of a new
series of shorter videos each of them focused on
One Core concept from an important philosophical
text I hope you find it useful as well in Thomas
aquinas's sumatelogai Prima pars question two
which has to do with the existence of God Thomas
Aquinas will tell us that there's five main ways
to argue for or to reveal the existence of God to
the interested querying person and the first of
these is actually from what we can translate as
change or a little bit more literally motion ex
parte motus right we'll talk about what maltus
means in just a moment because it's important
to create a dissociation between our present
day understanding of motion and the broader sense
that it has but he also says interestingly enough
that this way is the most evident or obvious or
clear manifesty order so that's why he starts with
the first way it's not set up like well if you
don't buy this then maybe you'll buy this all of
these are sort of complementary ways of arguing
for the existence of something that he'll he'll
say in the end this is what everybody calls
God right and we'll get to that in just a bit
so motion or change motives includes all sorts
of changing and it's not just like billiard
balls hitting each other and transferring a
certain amount of force to each other or you
know to use an example that uh Thomas will bring
up a little bit later in this this thing talking
about a stick a Bakula needing to be moved
by a hand if the hand does not move the stick
the stick won't move anything else right so it
includes that kind of motion but it also includes
Changing State you know coming into being being
corrupted or breaking down into things movement
and in place all those sorts of things and so
he'll use another example of fire causing wood
to become actually hot in this way causing change
causing motives in the wood so what is change so
Thomas is going to be using an Aristotelian
metaphysical framework in which what it is
to change is to go from potentiality potentia
possibility you could also say or power right
those are all ways of translating this a capacity
is another way going from potential to now it's
translated in different ways and I do want to
mention that the Blackfriars translation here
not the best because it talks about perfection in
Latin it's actually octus which we can translate
as the cognit ACT but also as actuality right
activity is kind of connected to this as well
so going from potential to actuality and you
know many things have the potential for many
different changes our bodies are a prime example
very complicated structure capable of being
you know in general healthy or sick right these
opposites that we can put together but then you
know healthy exists in many different ways and you
can be healthier we'll put all that aside for the
moment hopefully you've got your head around this
notion that what's happening when something is
changing is it's moving from a potentiality that
it has to an actuality of it a you know more of it
being what it is you could say now how does this
happen so Thomas points out that a thing by itself
cannot move itself from potentiality to actuality
it requires something else to do that and we call
this causation right and it can happen in a number
of different ways the second main way of proving
God's existence is going to rely on what we
call efficient causality but there's also for
Thomas Aquinas as for any Aristotelian material
causality final causality formal causality all of
these are connected together in interesting ways
so that's all set up that's contained within this
this article for the argument that's going to
be made so the argument itself goes like this
we notice that something in
the world is moved or changed
Mundo right and you know you could translate it
as just something in a very generic sense we could
say listen we see things plural in the process
of change including ourselves right but all these
other things around us sometimes we even make
things change you know I eat the breakfast it's
down in my stomach gets dissolved and digested and
it becomes more me right that's being transformed
in the process now Aquinas says we can grasp this
with our senses he's not saying that we can grasp
cause and effect with our senses he's saying that
what our senses take in is the fact that things do
change how do they change here's where we start
to move Beyond just sensibility and we start to
take on a metaphysical Viewpoint about the world
one that you know is is fairly common sensical
um you know we could say that scientists also
believe this and so do all sorts of other people
know effect without some sort of other thing
which is a cause which is taking the something
in the world that's moved from its potential to
actuality from its potencia to octaves so there's
something else he says by something else right so
he says that um to cause change is to bring into
being what was previously only able to be this
can only be done by something that already is
so there's a priority to the causer compared to
the caused or changed or moved the effect right
so this is something that is is in being has
actuality and it's causing something else to
have that so let's look at the example that
he uses now fire and wood he says that fire
um is actually hot right it's it's uh it
says secret uh kalidum in Octo it is hot
in act right and then the fire is touched to a
piece of wood a lignum and the wood is hot in
potential or in potency in potencia right it's
not yet hot and we took it in from outside from
the woodshed right so we put the wood on the
fire the fire is touching it now the wood is
able to get hot and combustion there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that we could talk about
going on there but you don't want to get too
far into the weeds with this so it causes the
wood which is able to be hot which has the
potential for that to become actually hot in
this way it causes change in the wood so prime
example there that I think is fairly intuitive
to wrap your head around and then we could say
all right well what caused this something else
it didn't like make itself just be what it is any
more than this thing did it didn't bring its own
potentiality potentiality to actuality so there
has to be another thing another cause behind that
and so on and so on and we can go back uh very
far with these sets these matrices of causes
could we go back endlessly to Infinity as
we say um and Thomas says Hulk outum known
as Pro quedere in infinitum right what does
that mean uh so this process cannot go back
procedure it cannot go on in infinitum endlessly
without any sort of limit why not so here's an
interesting part of the the argument right it's
not just well you just can't go back to Infinity
because you never get the entire process started
if you're just kicking the metaphysical can all
the way down the road you need to have some sort
of first mover or changer which is the bringing
of of other things out of their potentiality into
actuality that's what it does right so there has
to be a premium moves a first mover is how this
is said or else nothing happens and here's where
he brings up the example of the stick and the hand
it is only when acted on by the first cause right
that the intermediate causes will produce any
change if the hand doesn't move the stick the
stick will not move anything else so there
has to be some first cause of change right
we have to arrive fats or derive odd Ali quote
premam moves some sort of first mover quote
a nullo movetor which is not moved by anything
else and here we get the famous formula this all
understand as or by however you want to translate
it God Hulk omnis intelligent damn so one
way of understanding God would be as
this first mover or changer lacking which
no other movement or change could
really be taking place but we know
that it is taking place so therefore there
must be such a first mover and that is God